No one likes going to the dentist, but you
should all go every year.
Because really, do you want to risk an infection
in the biggest hole in your head?!
Hey guys, Amy talking the joys of oral hygiene
with you on DNews today!
As many as 700 types of bacteria can live
in our mouths, though most people only host
between 34 and 72 varieties.
Some of these bacteria are innocuous, others
known as probiotics actually help us digest
food.
There are even bacterial strains that protect
our teeth and gums.
But there are some bad bacteria living in
your mouth as well.
One is called streptococcus mutans.
This bacteria feeds on the sugars and starches
you eat, producing enamel-eroding acids as
a by-product, which can lead to tooth decay.
Another bad bacteria is porphyromonas gingivalis,
which is linked to periodontitis, a serious
and progressive disease that affects the soft
tissue and the alveolar bone that support
the teeth causing tooth pain and in some cases
tooth loss.
For most of us, our main dental issue will
be plaque, the film that builds up on your
teeth and contains the bacteria that produces
enamel-destroying acids.
Regular cleanings get rid of plaque, but if
you don’t clean the plaque from your teeth
it hardens into tartar, which can get below
your gums, causing inflammation and infection.
That can open a pathway into your bloodstream.
Once that bacteria is in your blood, it can
get anywhere.
The first place that bacteria-filled blood
could go is your heart where there is some
evidence that it can lead to atherosclerosis,
or a hardening of the arteries caused by plaque,
though this is a different kind of plaque
than you'd find on your teeth.
The plaque in your arteries is made of cholesterol,
fatty substances, cellular waste products,
calcium and a clotting agent called fibrin.
It builds up and thickens the walls of the
arteries, constricting blood flow and increasing
risk of a heart attack.
Clogged or blocked arteries can also restrict
blood flow to the brain, increasing risk of
stroke.
A recent single hospital study in Osaka, Japan,
found that a quarter of stroke victims had
a bacteria called cnm-positive S. mutans in
their saliva.
The researchers acknowledged that it’s a
rare bacteria only 10 percent of people have,
but it’s still enough to reinforce the link
between the oral bacterium and stroke.
And mouth bacteria can even follow a path
to your brain, increasing risk of dementia.
A 2013 study from the University of Central
Lancashire found a correlation between the
bacteria commonly associated with gingivitis
and an immune response that may kill neurons.
This could ultimately change the brain in
a way consistent with Alzheimer’s disease.
And, if that weren't bad enough, letting bacteria
form colonies in your mouth can also lead
to lung infections, but not through the bloodstream…
Instead you literally breathe oral microbes
into your lungs, where it can infect and spread.
And your oral health doesn’t just impact
your body health, it can be a good indicator
of your overall health.
For example: gum disease can be a sign of
diabetes, painful mucosal lesions are more
common in people who are HIV positive, and
tooth weakness or loss can be a sign of osteoporosis.
So it should be said that this is a huge “more
research is needed” topic since most studies
have small sample sizes and need follow-up
work.
And experts somewhat begrudgingly admit that
we just don’t know yet whether treating
gum disease can reduce the risk of heart attack,
stroke, or dementia.
But, really, do you need more motivation for
keeping up with dental visits than maintaining
good teeth for chewing?
Floss!
Brush!
And above all: go to the dentist!
And speaking of painful things in your mouth,
confused about the difference between canker
sores and cold sores?
We were, too, so Trace explains it in this
video right here.
So how many of you always go in your yearly
dental cleaning?
I do!
Let us know in the comments below and don’t
forget to subscribe for DNews every day of
the week.